[Music]
Hey sister what you going do going down
by the river going to play
[Music]
SC
woman in the midd of be all right be all
[Music]
right
come on we're going to be light oh hush
just live a little Let it
[Music]
wait it's Sunday morning
so make a
[Music]
Jo to
[Applause]
[Music]
the in the king through Daniel in the
Lion's ve the Lord works in mysterious
way God said a mighty Angel brought him
out
again Works mysterious way God so the
wicked he know what to do bring the
animals to my cuz I'm going to keep your
for 40
days works in mysterious way yes he
works he works look works in mysterious
way
oh your works mysterious
[Applause]
way
[Music]
mysterious let's get a move on Sil slow
as mud she going as fast as she can po
she say the baby been
kicking what you going to call your baby
CH if it's a boy I'mma name him Adam
like in the Bible ain't that precious Dy
T get up here
[Applause]
yes still works my God still
works still works in mysterious
way none of us knows what the Lord's got
planed for us no sir s sa morning qu
graning thr away a h and put your hand
in his and follow where he leads the
good Lord walking with you walking with
you the good Lord talking with you
talking with
you
[Music]
[Applause]
singing walk
talking
talking walk talking
[Music]
[Applause]
mysterious
[Music]
way and with her strength the girl R
return to work in the field but it was
so hot she could barely stand the
overseer yelled at her till she got to
her feet frightened she turned to her
mama and asked let me say it this my
favorite part just like Mama used to
read it the girl was floating above the
ground but she wasn't flying yet she got
nervous that the overseer would catch
her and without fake she fell to the
ground
hard
when can I wear it mom not now baby but
soon
mhm this color is going to look like
heaven on
you all
right now give me your hand I want you
to feel a needle feel it I want you to
feel the claw feel it yes M all right I
want you to try
okay don't be scared don't be
scared P push it through there that's
good that's
good I broke my water hold still I'll
get the
midb you're doing just fine missile I
just need you to push one more
time almost there
[Applause]
[Music]
one more push
come it's a little
boy there he
is here's
[Music]
mommmy
you n that baby
here had a boy Paul and a here I'll give
him the guard same as I did the
other let me have just one more day with
him
no I can help CA with the baby I'll even
help pull some of her weight around the
house no that baby mine I'll take him if
I want to give him
here
[Music]
you think he killed my
babies I believe he give him to God just
like he
say but they
mad
how come God don't give him
back
afternoon more like early evening but
howdy early evening that means it's
getting late girl let me give you ride
home I ain't nobody's girl but my mom
and she dead you can call me
NY it got some real pretty
teeth
n
lordy and your skin dazzled my eyes like
the Moonlight the night and he poetical
too that's a real pretty dress
my sister made
it and your
shoes look just right on them pretty
little
feet now you lying I'm tomboy and I
likes to climb trees I got corns bunions
and blisters ain't nothing pretty about
my feet now leave me
be name's mister
[Music]
come think got
both